I am so sorry it turns out I was
completely wrong with my last video he's
not actually a pillow by Chef he's a
home cook who went to the best culinary
school around his mom's kitchen to our
harsh preservatives these two are
actually really common allergens it's a
growing problem because people like him
have been scaring people about parabens
glycol put it back that's what gives it
its kind of glossy Sheen when you put it
on but it's a skin irritant animal it's
actually really non-irritating unless
you're allergic like every other
ingredient kinda ironic because he has
Dairy on his shirt to understand why
they're such even the ewg page he just
showed doesn't say it's a hormone
disruptor he just made that up
yes that's the whole reason these
products clean and they can be
formulated to be gentle they make your
hair brittle I don't think he knows what
an essential oil is hair essential oil
is not a thing it's coming from
artificial colors if it came from green
tea it'd be oxidized and brown basically
vitamin A it does make retinal permitate
causing cancer was debunked 12 years ago